donald trump held a huge rally this
weekend
wait what yes he lost the election
yes there's a raging pandemic with
record cases and deaths
and yes trump's rally in georgia had a
huge crowd huge crowd very few masks and
went almost into a third hour of trump
ranting
and trump is still insisting he won the
election the rally hilariously
was ostensibly to support the two
republican senate candidates running in
georgia
trump devoted about 20 minutes of the
nearly three hours to them he's just too
self-centered and narcissistic
uh to make it about them and you've got
to see this to believe it as i mentioned
this was almost fidel castro like in
nature trump almost went into a third
hour
in valdosta georgia ranting about
whatever crossed his mind
and the upside is this will end soon he
is only president six and a half more
weeks my friend so let's dive directly
into it
because we have a lot to get to trump
kicking off the rally with the lie
that he won the state of georgia
[Applause]
thank you very much and thank you
melania and i want to say
hello georgia we did a great job
you know we won georgia just so you
understand
so trump of course lost georgia joe
biden
won georgia and as scary as it is that a
president still says this a full month
after an election
it's scarier that a crowd of thousands
is cheering it
that's really the scary part hilariously
trump almost admitted that he lost but
then he backpedaled realizing he was
about
to implicitly concede take a look at
this
i think they say that if you win florida
and if you win ohio in history you've
never lost an election this has got to
be your first time
but the truth is they were right we've
never lost an election we're winning
this election
and and of course again
the fact that people cheer for these
lies is horrifying
trump wasn't just declaring non-existent
victories electorally
he also declared victory in the
christmas war
the war on christmas a fake phony
non-existent war let me begin by wishing
you all a very merry christmas remember
the word
remember we started five years ago and i
said you're going to be saying christmas
again and we say it proudly again
although they'll they'll be trying to
take that word again out of the
vocabulary we're not going to let them
do that
that war doesn't exist neither did the
war on thanksgiving that he talked about
just weeks ago
and then donald trump falsely claimed
that a lot of people are already
vaccinated from kovid that was weird
and let me also express our warmest best
wishes and love to all of those people
and families suffering from the
covet pandemic vaccines are on their way
at a level that nobody ever thought
possible it would have taken another
administration
five years it took us seven months
and they're starting next week and we're
gonna start vaccinating and
a lot of people already are vaccinated
it's called you have
you caught it and you're immune now of
course nobody's been vaccinated other
than the people that were part of the
clinical trials for the vaccines
trump i guess meant people who got the
virus and recovered are immune
just as a reminder we don't know how
long immunity
from recovered patients lasts it's
unclear whether
you are immune longer if you had a more
serious case of the virus versus an
asymptomatic case as an example
very dangerous for trump to be spreading
this type of stuff when we have a raging
pandemic
another incredible moment was trump
telling people
to vote for kelly leffler and david
perdue in the upcoming senate runoffs
while in the same breath saying it's
completely rigged which as we talked
about earlier might actually convince
people not to vote
our estate has had this prominence on
senate races
because they're never together and
this is something that's very important
and you have to get out you have to vote
you have to make sure you have every
vote counted
everybody has to count you got to make
sure they don't throw away any ballots
you got to make sure that when they
collect the ballots and they start
bragging about how many ballots they
already have you got to make sure your
secretary of state knows what the hell
he's doing
and you got to make sure your governor
gets a lot tougher than he's been he's
got to get a lot tougher
you really should vote but it's rigged
trump also attacking the georgia
governor
uh brian kemp and the georgia secretary
of state brad raffensberger just
out of this world lunacy at this rally
then trump pulled out the c-word
uh no not that one that you might
imagine he would use about kamala harris
this is
communism about joe biden and kamal
harris
of course there's not a single
communistic idea in joe biden's platform
not a single socialist idea in the
campaign nor in the incoming
administration
so far these people want to go further
than socialism they want to go into a
communistic form of government and i
have no doubt about it
somehow that doesn't suit georgia too
well that's not
now of course if you go up to anybody at
that rally
and you say yes good evening sir or
ma'am which
biden policies are communistic ask them
what communism even
is it will get very embarrassing very
quickly but they're continuing to harp
on this meme which by the way
the meme might have won george florida
for trump
it's conceivable that florida went that
way because the the socialism meme
worked
on cuban americans in florida so i'm not
pretending it doesn't work
i'm just telling you it's bonkers and
then a completely
kafka-esque moment when trump read from
printed out sheets of paper
that have so-called irrefutable facts
about the election take a look at this
or a rigged election there's no way it
could have happened you know it's uh
it's interesting i wrote this out and i
had just a few of the facts which i
think because i want to get onto the
presidentials
i want to i want to stay on presidential
but i got to get to these two because
they're incredible
but listen to this these are the facts
and each fact is like
irrefutable and it means win
president trump received done by one of
the most brilliant
political people president trump
received more votes
than any previous incumbent president in
history
and we lost and we lost
so we received more votes than anybody
in history any incumbent in history we
lost supposedly we didn't lose
we're gonna you're gonna see that no
incumbent who received 75
of the total primary vote lost
reelection in the history of our country
every single one of these of course has
a but trump received more votes than any
previous incumbent
but still millions of fewer votes than
joe biden
an incumbent with 75 percent of the
primary vote
has never previously lost but there
really wasn't a republican primary this
year because of the pandemic and the
number is not causal it's a
correlational number in any case
the entire night was like this again and
again
and just literally hours of it trump
still then
after you know he ranted for two hours
and then still hasn't figured out that
the election is over listen to this one
gordon they want to hurt it very badly
and if these two don't get in
or if i don't get into these two we
gotta get
the best would be all three nothing will
happen
[Applause]
[Music]
then there's a hilarious moment where
trump is talking about who knows what
at a rally supposedly from georgia uh
for
georgia senate candidates these are just
non-sequitur rantings i don't know what
he's talking about here
like to say it came from europe no
actually well specifically it came from
italy
italy saying what did we do
the wage war on american energy
absolutely decimating georgia's middle
class they will
your bills will go up not a huge energy
producer but texas remember they said
trump will lose texas by a lot i said
wait a minute i'm in favor of energy i'm
the one that built we have the greatest
energy we've ever had
that is trump rallying in support of
georgia senate candidates
imagine what he would be doing if he was
trying to hurt them rather than help
and then trump claims to have won
wisconsin which he lost
how much and we knew that before but
it's fake news they said wisconsin
a poll came out washington post abc
just before the election i'm going to
lose wisconsin by 17 points i said no
i'm going to win wisconsin
well actually i won wisconsin they're
trying to say he's a little down
but i actually won
and then one more bizarre moment donald
trump talking about the vegetables he
likes
blueberries peppers squash and cucumbers
who
who does cucumbers around here because i
like cucumbers can you i'm the only one
i like you [ __ ] absolute
absolute last one trump wrongly telling
people they really need to vote on june
5th
the election is actually on january 5th
but everything that we've achieved
together is on the line on june 5th
so this is funny and you know to see the
the delusional petulant child who still
can't admit he lost but it is really
really dangerous this is corrosive to
democracy this is a global
embarrassment and this also has the
potential to be stochastic terrorism
trump is railing against poll workers
against the secretary
of state against governors against
democrats against biden saying he stole
it they stole it it's all stolen
this actually can inspire people to
violence and we've already seen
people inspired by these rantings to
start harassing and going after poll
workers in georgia and even other states
so
this has a very real world component
it's not just corrosive to democracy
ideologically
it also actually could inspire real
violence against people
and um again just a few more weeks of
this
just a few more weeks of this let's take
a quick break we will be back
with very much more in just mere moments
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently checked
out the book podcast marketing strategy
by daniel rolls and kieran rogers and
so useful so particularly applicable to
what i'm doing
really recommend it blinkist has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different non-fiction categories and
a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video